put a finger down if you had a boyfriend
of a year and a half and he was your
best friend and the best thing that ever
happened to you and everyone was
convinced you were gonna get married and
he was going to a super prestigious
college to play d1 baseball and you plan
on going to the same college as him and
you're so excited that's very [ __ ]
specific it's not supposed to be like
it's not supposed to work like that it's
put a finger down if and in a small
freaking sentence like put your finger
down if you ever get beaten put your
finger down if you
that put your finger down and you're
reading me your pedigree girl what the
[ __ ] this is not supposed to be an essay
it's supposed to be a small sentence i
stopped listening to you i don't know i
can't who has a boyfriend and then you
play baseball you went through the same
procedure
halfway in your [ __ ]
put a finger down if you decide to have
a one night stand woke up in the morning
checked your butthole and found out that
you have herpes no no one else uh some
of y'all [ __ ] needs to need you
need a dairy
[Music]
you need
any diary you need the [ __ ] right
[ __ ] down and at the end of winter he
went on a family vacation to mexico and
while he was in mexico you went to a
mutual friend's house party and when you
got to the party you saw your
boyfriend's childhood best friend drunk
driving a whole bunch of kids home so
you decided to be a good person and get
in the car and take all the kids home
and when you're driving your boyfriend's
best friend back to the party he pulled
his pants down and told you to pull over
on the side of the road and he said no
because you love your boyfriend and you
continue to say no about 10 more times
but your boyfriend's best friend didn't
care and spent a half hour trying to
convince you to get in the backseat of
his acura it was the middle of the night
and you were terrified and you no idea
where your phone was and you finally
gave in and you never told your way from
what happened because you were too
scared your boyfriend would kill the kid
oh [ __ ] i gotta put a finger down
i mean what mine was a dodge but [ __ ]
pretty [ __ ] accurate i'm sorry girl
you're right
okay listen
i don't know the particulars of this
girl's situation or how it happened that
night
but if i found out
but you have to pull over and get in the
back seat
listen i'm not i'm not going there i'm
not going there i'm not no no no listen
listen listen i'm not going there i'm
not doing that i'm not commenting on
that basically she got in a situation
maybe she got scared i cannot speak on
my position
i cannot speak in my position of
privilege where if that should happen to
me i want to be scared so i don't know
what a situation is maybe it was it was
just the whole finger down all right
that's
you got pressured into whatever but the
whole finger down thing girl
i like actually told the traumatic story
like listen i'm tired of these fingers
that's that's your takeaway
it's just it's just the way you said the
story was not what it is unless there's
details missing i know maybe there's a
threat involved or somebody who knows i
don't know we don't know i don't know
what position it is or whatever so i'm
not going to be like oh yeah you should
have gotten out of what no we're not
you're asking me you got in the back
seat you have to pull over again we're
not doing that you're not you're i am
okay i'm not by myself on this island
you're toxic listen listen listen if
this is castaway it's just me and the
ball no it's not no because i'm right
there
if they can drag you for this [ __ ]
they're gonna drive me too
it's beaufort well there you go both of
us both us
hey we'll listen i'll be off u.s i'll
take that it's beaufort i don't know
yeah
and get himself in trouble and lose his
baseball scholarship and get himself in
trouble and lose his baseball
scholarship and you were so proud of him
and he worked so hard so you decided to
do what was best for your boyfriend
because you always did what was best for
your boyfriend because you loved him
more than you loved yourself even though
after you didn't let your boyfriend of a
year and a half touch you sexually for
months and months because you were so
emotionally damaged from what happened
and the thought of a guy touching you
made you want to vomit everywhere and
you lost a ton of weight and was
sleeping 24 7 and your mom thought you
were super sick but you and your
boyfriend stayed together the whole time
because you thought he loved you and
let's go by and you go to another house
party and your boyfriend doesn't want to
go with you and you get super drunk and
you see your ex-boyfriend and you tell
your ex-boyfriend everything that
happened to you when your boyfriend was
in mexico he said wow it's really messed
up you think hey your ex-boyfriend's
right and you keep talking to him about
what happened and all your friends get
super concerned that you're spending so
much time with your ex-boyfriend so they
go and tell your boyfriend a year and a
half that i think you're cheating on him
with your ex-boyfriend and your
boyfriend have a year and a half breaks
up with you based off suspicions that
you're cheating on him the [ __ ] out
what i had sympathy for you get the [ __ ]
out what'd you mean what the [ __ ] you
mean she went for the back back with the
boyfriend
no no so she the guy
she's had the same boyfriend the whole
time but
one night she decided to go to a party
and her ex-boyfriend just happened to be
there yeah they started talking and
she's been just telling him so she
confided in him but she couldn't
convince her
so she didn't get with them so until you
talk to your boyfriend your ex-boyfriend
not him yeah so was that another story
your boyfriend broke up with you
what's the end of the story well
they the
the friends of the girl told the
boyfriend that she cheated because she's
with the x guy but she didn't she was
just telling them stories i i'll take
you think she's cheating wow is what i
think
i think the story's never bad as people
make it out to be and the story is never
as
sympathetic as she makes it out to be
when i hear her tell this story can i
ask you in this whole story has she
taken accountability for anything once
no that's not the point
but what i'm trying to say is in a story
this long
with this many things happening has she
taken accountability once my point being
is that now she's talking to the
ex-boyfriend she's sharing all the
details with him the women have gone to
tell the boyfriend that oh she's
cheating she doesn't even acknowledge
that she may have done weird things in
regards to not telling her she's just
like how could he break up with me
give him what i'm trying to say
throughout this whole that's why i look
people funny if you don't take
accountability because that one you can
definitely and you try to prop you up as
you know that's what i was saying when i
was answering a question is that the
whole time of this story she's like yeah
and i did this and i did that and i did
that and i did that cause i'm this and
i'm supporting on this and that and the
point of the story was not to put
herself to put a finger down but it was
to put herself up
but
i i think this is just some this so her
ex-boyfriend can see this and take her
back yes i'm pretty sure if i talk to
the ex-boyfriend he's like uh you heard
oh i got some stories yeah i got stories
based off suspicions that you're
cheating on him but you're still in
contact with your boyfriend so one day
you meet up with him and he sees your ex
boyfriend's name on your phone and goes
home and blocks you on everything which
makes you hysterical because even though
you're broken up you still spent almost
every single day of the last year and a
half with your boyfriend so you
literally have to go to his house
unannounced and beg on his front
doorstep to see him when your boyfriend
finally agrees to talk to you you
finally tell him what actually happened
when he went to mexico and how one of
his best friends borderline assault you
but your boyfriend doesn't care and he
says it's your fault and you still
cheated on him so he goes home and tells
all of his friends and his entire family
that you spend every single holiday with
for the last year and a half and all his
cousins that you babysit on a regular
basis that you cheated on him and you
start to get text messages from your
boyfriend's family and all of his
friends saying you're a terrible person
so you run away and the police are out
looking for you so you decide to come
home but before you go home you want to
tell your boyfriend you're safe so you
go to his house but you see your best
friend's white mazda in his driveway so
you lose your mind and you have to go to
a mental hospital and when you get home
from the mental hospital you see one
friend and she tells you that the
employees at chipotle saw your boyfriend
and your best friend out getting food
together so now you really lose your
mind
but your boyfriend cannot get food with
your restaurant
but you can talk with your ex
what is this
what do when you say what what is the i
don't know i had your back lady wait you
it's cool if you talk with your ex
but he can't talk with your best friend
and i'll admit that and that makes you
lose your mind but your but your
boyfriend or your ex is a dog for even
insinuating
when he said hey let me i'm just hey
hold on that was a group miss some
spoils on that island make some space on
that island
[Music]
can we appreciate
i went with my sneaking suspicions you
felt something with suss i was just
waiting for and i went on a limb and i
knew it and you know what they could
have gotten mad i would have been cool
with it because i owned that [ __ ]
and then you started sniffing a little
bit more with
oh i smell it too [ __ ]
i smell it too
hey wait a [ __ ] minute wait you know
what that smells like
cap
that's what that sounds like yeah what's
the same i thought i was on the
different i'm on the peninsula listen
same thing listen i'm on the keys looks
the part of florida let's go let's go
you delete all social media off of your
phone you go off the grid don't talk to
anybody for weeks and weeks your whole
family has to fly home because your
parents took off so many days of work to
take care of you this is your first
social media post in months and you
still haven't heard from your boyfriend
or your best friend to this day
it's not your boyfriend no more he he
i'm not wow first we're not putting our
finger down and secondly he's not your
boyfriend he blocks you
you're done girl
uh
system of a down
the toxicity
okay
don't don't call him your boyfriend
[ __ ]
okay so he was in a bunch of tick tocks
what happened i guess this is the
boyfriend
so this is them taking a bunch of stuff
oh that's awkward oh wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait something
just dawned on me what
she's talking about prom dress is this
mission high school
do you want to commit they going to
college this is like high school [ __ ]
oh
listen man you know what
you know what
i take back everything
i take back everything i said
let me just say this high schoolers are
crazy it's a crazy time period
everyone's hormonal folks are just doing
a lot of crazy stuff what's true what's
not i got no clue i got no clue you know
what i got nothing else to add we
talking about [ __ ] teenagers anything
you want to say no all right my
apologies patreon hopefully you guys
enjoy this exclusive
[ __ ] this island is hot